[Music]
we warned you in a past video here on
visualpolitik south korea's new
president the conservative yoon sok yol
is turning out to be a political
earthquake since he took over the
presidency not a week goes by without
yoon announcing some major change in the
country of course given the track record
of south korean presidents when it comes
to keeping their promises we will have
to keep a close eye on what is finally
done and not done
[Music]
after all in the history of south korean
democracy presidents fulfill on average
around 30 percent of their election
pledges because yes in south korea these
things are counted former president moon
for example met just 17 according to
provisional data of course we are
talking about statistics and that
doesn't always work in politics not all
commitments carry the same weight be
there as it may the fact that president
yoon does not come from professional
korean politics may make his statistics
much better for now if there is one
thing we can say it is that the guy
looks like he's got the drive
[Music]
for the time being the vision of south
korea that the new president seems to
want to create is quite different from
the one left by former president moon
now do you want to know exactly what the
first steps are that yoon is taking to
revive south korea could they be the
gateway to a new economic takeoff what
does this president's promise shift to
the right consist of in practice well in
this video we will answer these and
other questions
[Music]
visualpolitik fans south korea's
political system is presidential but
perhaps one of its most notable
characteristics is that legislative and
presidential elections do not coincide
on the same date that is the country's
president may have to govern without a
majority in parliament this is precisely
the scenario that yoon seok yol
encountered specifically between 10th of
may 2022 when he assumed the presidency
and april 2024 he will have no choice
but to govern with a hostile parliament
this means that for at least two of the
five years of his mandate the president
may be tied hand and foot if he does not
get the support of the opposition in the
national assembly all that during this
time he decides to govern more or less
by presidential decree which is exactly
what seems to be going to happen
[Music]
in south korea the legislative chamber
is not required to approve each and
every presidential decree which gives
the president broad powers basically
allowing him to introduce major changes
without the need to reach a large
consensus and although in the long run
these measures can be easily reversed
they can have important consequences on
the political economic and social life
of the country
[Music]
for the time being the first proposals
and the first changes are already here
judge for yourselves
more market and less state
[Music]
as we already mentioned in the last
video about the turnaround in south
korea if there is one thing that
categorizes yoon it is that he does not
like anything absolutely anything that
carries the slightest whiff of left-wing
politics neither socially nor
economically also he says be that as it
may it is in the economic area where
most changes are expected to take place
in the coming years and they are so
important what do you want me to say we
are obliged to tell you about them on
visualpolitik well first of all the new
president has already announced the
central measures of his five-year
economic plan they are already public so
we are not talking about promises or
imaginings but about firm intentions and
among them reducing regulations on
business activity and lowering taxes are
the clear protagonists
regulations and schemes that undermine
business competitiveness and discourage
entrepreneurship will be drastically
improved the current economic
circumstance inside and outside the
country are very serious in times of
crisis we need to make changes to be
more market-orientated and have the
private sector drive the entire economy
yoon syuk yul in fact both finance
minister chu kyung-ho and other
ministers have made it very clear in a
statement that the core of the young
government's economic plan will be
deregulation above all else
[Music]
the new economic plan commits the
government to minimizing state
intervention in the market and to
promoting a change in the economic model
towards one in which private sectors and
companies are the dominant players
likewise the plan also includes reducing
the top corporate tax rate from 25
percent to 22 percent the same level as
it was in 2018 thus reversing the
increases led by moon jai in also and
importantly a revision of the tax system
is proposed to introduce a tax exemption
for profits repatriated to south korea
the aim is to resolve once and for all
the problem of double taxation on the
activities of south korean companies
abroad
and that's not the end of it
yoon naturally also wants more
entrepreneurship and startups to be
created in south korea so in order to
achieve this his idea is to grant
greater tax credits for example by
extending exemptions for stock options a
form of employee compensation that
consists of the delivery of shares in
the company's own stock from the current
threshold of 50 million won the new
government wants to quadruple the tax
exemption to 200 million won about 154
000 in other words if you are
compensated in shares up to that amount
you would not be taxed with this the
government hopes to attract more highly
qualified workers to the startups and
that they will be able to be paid a good
chunk of their salary in shares instead
of cash the company wins the workers win
and the government wins if it increases
the number of startups and don't forget
that we're talking about south korea in
this country people dream of working in
large conglomerates thanks to the high
salaries which allows the large
companies to behave as a kind of talent
vacuum cleaner that damages the
competitiveness of small companies that
are generally underdeveloped we've
already told you about the enormous
problem of duality that south korea has
in this area they are almost two
different countries then another of the
economic measures announced is the
modification of the inheritance tax and
take note because this is not a minor
issue
those of you who have been following us
for a while on visualpolitik may have
already seen this video but for those of
you who haven't i think these headlines
say quite a lot
an inheritance tax bill you can't fathom
10.8 billion dollars the samsung family
in south korea will also donate billions
of dollars worth of art including
picasso and monet
high inheritance tax hampering
entrepreneurship and visualpolitik fans
although south korea has one of the
lowest fiscal pressures in the oecd
dying on the other hand can be very very
expensive provided that is that you have
money because according to the korean
national tax service only 2.9 of the
heirs of deceased persons had to pay
this tax in 2020. but if we're talking
about attacks that in south korea can be
up to 50 percent even between parents
and children following a progressive
scale with deductions in the best income
tax style now do you understand why the
heirs of lee kun hee the former chairman
of samsung group which is the country's
largest business conglomerate have to
face such a hefty bill
[Music]
well although this tax mainly affects
people who have a lot of money whether
you think it is fair or not is up to you
it is true that its impact on the
economy can be considerable you see
since major business conglomerates in
south korea are family owned and
therefore inherited when someone passes
away the bill can be so high that it can
end up affecting the company itself when
it comes to undertaking new investments
or hiring workers for example the heirs
may end up going into debt to pay the
tax by pledging company resources as
collateral and above all this encourages
many people to take money out of the
country and start businesses abroad well
whether you like it or not this is
something that yoon wants to change but
even he doesn't seem to know exactly how
he's going to do it
[Music]
apart from the measure just mentioned
yoon's plan also includes other very
important tax measures such as the
abolition of capital gains tax for all
investors whose profits do not exceed 15
500 per year in return the idea is to
apply a small tax on those holding more
than 7.7 million dollars in shares it
would also allow the postponement of
gift tax payments in the case of
receiving a business from a family
member and tax incentives for
investments in strategic technologies
such as semiconductors will be extended
well this is how yoon wants to make the
south korean economy much more
competitive and possibly able to weather
the crisis that seems to be looming but
wait a minute because the tax missions
are far from the only changes yoon wants
to push through there is much more to
his flagship plan to restore south korea
to its former momentum listen up
the 180 degree turn
visualpolitik fans the change yoon has
in mind is not just about lowering four
taxes and leaving it at that nothing
could be further from the truth the new
president wants to make a u-turn on some
of the most controversial and sensitive
matters such as energy policy and
pensions for example yoon seems ready to
fulfill one of his big promises one of
the star proposals of his campaign to
bet heavily on nuclear energy in fact
the prime minister has already announced
a preview of the plan that seeks to meet
the carbon neutrality target by 2050 but
instead of doing so with renewables as
the main source he wants nuclear power
to be the main player and renewables to
be the backup
union calls for rational energy mix what
he means by rational above all is that
moons form a plan for decarbonization
seems anything but realistic the
previous government's model combines the
progressive closure of nuclear plants
with a wild commitment to renewables the
problem is that in order to carry it out
the weight of renewables had to increase
to between 61 and 71 of the energy mix
something that most experts consider
simply not feasible
on the other hand the new government has
already announced that it will resume
construction of the two nuclear reactors
cancelled by the previous government of
moon jae-in that it will also extend the
useful life of those that are nearing
their limit and that's not all it also
plans to launch the construction of
several new nuclear reactors to increase
the share of nuclear energy in
electricity production from 27.1 to 34
in the medium term while also seek to
introduce small modular reactors or smrs
which are emerging as major players in
the future of nuclear power into the
country the government will continue to
support the deployment of renewable
energies however the ultimate goal is to
eliminate gas and coal-fired power
generation which currently account for
66 percent of south korea's energy mix
by 2050
then on the issue of housing the
economic plan envisages reducing taxes
on landlords so they can reduce the
prices of rent and gions the peculiar
south korean rental system based on a
gigantic rental deposit but without a
monthly fee
a short term risks remain in the lease
market the government seeks to make
preemptive responses by extending tax
and financial benefits and boosting
supplies chu kyung ho finance minister
on this last matter on the supply side
the government has pledged to soon
unveil a plan to build 2.5 million new
homes in the country we shall see but
perhaps the most delicate reform of all
is precisely that of pensions
[Music]
you see south korea is the country with
the most accelerated demographic aging
in the oecd and its current pension
model based on a funded system through a
public pension fund is not expected to
be able to cope with the number of
pensioners in the near future president
yoon himself has clearly stated that in
his opinion the current model is a
burden for future generations therefore
among other measures he wants to
increase the minimum retirement age from
60 to 65 or even eliminate the
retirement age or grant benefits to
companies to rehire retirees what is
known as active retirement
and take note because this is no joke
according to the south korean statistics
office the working age population will
shrink by more than 35 over the next
three decades a phenomenon that
threatens to sink production while
public spending could skyrocket not only
in pensions but also in health and
social services but this topic is so
significant that we will dedicate an
upcoming video specifically to it but
that does not mean that we are
absolutely finished i've already told
you that this new president has come in
with a vengeance
public institution reform is a task that
cannot be delayed any further public
institution evaluations must be
conducted strictly finances must only be
used where they are needed and financial
resources must be spent kindly and
generously on the truly social weak who
desperately need government support yoon
seok seok-ul we will see how that all
turns out for the time being what has
also changed radically has been the
foreign policy now much closer to the
united states and japan and more
belligerence towards china and north
korea which has meant abandoning the
equidistance of the previous moon
government on major foreign policy
issues take a look at this
biden yoon mull more military exercises
amid north korea tensions
south korea's alignment with u.s at odds
with china analysts say as a new south
korean government deepens the nation's
economic and security ties with the
united states experts are warning that
seoul's long-standing relationship with
china is likely to suffer
as soon as possible we have to go back
to the best days of korea and japan
unless we achieve that even though we
are talking about the future of asia i
don't think it's realistic yoon duk min
new south korean ambassador to japan
well i think with all that that we have
told you the question is clear do you
think that if all these measures are
really implemented south korea could
once again experience a new economic
takeoff do you think these measures are
enough to restore the country's
competitiveness at home and abroad leave
us your answers below and now if you
found this video interesting don't
forget to like it and subscribe to
visualpolitik to keep up to date with
all our news once again thank you very
much for being there all the best i'll
see you next time
[Music]